when it comes to the cost of living
crisis there is one key statistic to
keep an eye on here it's inflation the
race at which the average shopping
basket of goods and services goes up
each year and well you can see the big
picture here this goes back the past
decade and just look at how much that
line has gone up over 10 percent just
recently it's come down from 10.1 to 9.9
so a little bit of good news there
primarily though it's because of petrol
prices petrol prices pushing that down
uh quite a lot but if you strip away all
of the volatile stuff like energy like
food you're left with this this is core
inflation it's worth just looking at
because it gives you a sense of just the
underlying strength of inflation
although it's lower you can see that
it's still rising
and the expectation is that inflation is
going to go higher but how much higher
well that's just changed a lot because
remember the energy price guarantee that
the government just announced that could
make an enormous difference here here's
a forecast that came before that energy
price guarantee so this is the next few
months
and many economists thought that
inflation was going to get up towards 20
if you can believe it but now look at
the new forecast after the government
stepped in to guarantee uh those bills
not going above a certain level per unit
look a massive difference there so
inflation's still going up a little bit
in the next few months but coming down
uh to about the kind of bank of
england's target by kind of late next
year into 2024 so that's a big change
there but of course
the price of that for the government and
for the rest of us depends on this the
wholesale price of gas that's been
incredibly high recently although you
can see look at the right hand side you
can see it ramped up a bit but it
started to come down recently partly
because of what's happening all that
good news in ukraine so we're going to
keep an eye on that no one really knows
what's going to happen next final thing
to note you know i was talking about one
type of inflation so the type that we
tend to look at cpi basket of goods and
services but there is another type of
inflation house price inflation and that
actually this red line here is going up
even faster than regular inflation up by
more than 15 the highest rate actually
that's been since 2003 and i'll leave
you with with a statistic over the past
year the average home has gone up in
value by 39 000 pounds average earnings
over that period so typically what we
earn
31 000 pounds so homes earning more than
human beings it's quite a stark
statistic particularly if you're not yet
on the housing ladder